hey guys merry here for gamespot's the
mix at e3 2015 i'm here with Sam Abbott
well thanks for being here from
compulsion games hey well thanks for
having us and you're going to show me a
game that I think is absolutely
fascinating it's just like the concept
that's just something I've never heard
of before it's called we happy few it is
alright let's I want to get right into
it and you explain a little bit about
what you're trying to do here sure so we
happy few years again it's a survival
roguelike style game but its first
person which is what you consider right
now it's it in an alternate version of
the 1960s an alternative vision of
England in the southwest and what's
happened is that something in the past
has gone horribly wrong with this
society they basically got invaded
during World War two the Germans steam
rolled over England because for various
reasons but something bad happened while
they were there and as a way of coping
with it the society invented a drug and
vented a drug called joy and there a
society that just desperately wants to
be happy absolutely everything in the
world is revolves around happiness
including taking this drug called joy
now drug the joy makes me very very
happy it makes you really contingent OTT
really worried about a lot of things
except of course for the people who
aren't happy okay because they
threatened to break you up from your
kind of delusional mindset and your by
killing you well yeah I mean they kind
of kill you but they also don't they
really just want you to take your joy so
they knock you out and they force-feed
you with joy the problem with joy is
that it makes you forget everything so
every time you lose you die we actually
regenerate the entire world around you
okay so it's a procedurally generated
world this is what we're looking at
right now it's absolutely stunning I
mean in terms of these this type of game
I had no idea how beautiful the world
would actually be it's it's really it's
really wonderful and you get a you get a
little bit of a bioshock vibe from it
it's just incredibly eerie you know
something's wrong and it's got a little
bit of a post-apocalyptic than going on
here too so it's pretty dark environment
when you tell me a little bit actually I
really interested in that inventory
system okay see what just happened there
can I look at that inventory system so
so yeah basically you run around and get
a little bunch of stuff that is you
right bad man you are a sad slightly
worried man because everybody is out to
get you yep so you run around you
collect a whole bunch of things we just
actually had a joy pill which you can
see raised our little purple meter down
on the bottom okay and the AI in the
game they respond differently to your
depending on how much joy you have in
your system that's right so how drugs
you are basic alright it's not drugs
what does that entail they're happier
with anyone get happier with you yeah
drive absolutely but of course because
you're pumped full of drugs things
probably aren't that good for you so
okay um you have serious consequences
for taking any of the drugs so one of
the survival aspects of the game oh and
now you're in trouble oh no your solo
dude she is a very sad lady take her out
how we get helping once it my gosh um
very hurt she is a poor sad woman and we
have just terribly beaten her in her
house no she's a she is a one of these
people that we call a wastrel okay joy
did not work on her she's one of the one
of the people on the outside of Missouri
yeah well we don't want anyone else to
find her body right they'll get very
very grumpy she'll be safe up there
you'll be safe she'll be fine she's just
resting it's his corpse but I'm sure I'm
sure she's just fine so got some food
from her is that what we took we got
some food um I think it might have been
rotten so it's probably not a good idea
to her hey we could risk it if we're
really hungry we could what put me not
going to because how we actually haven't
put food poisoning cure into the game
yet so that's probably not the best but
going with the ol rock yep but what we
need to do is we need to get through
this gate over here ok but this gate is
basically saying hey are you on your
medicine today and we've got a very
polite little lady I'm gonna push her
out of the way we're gonna jump into our
joy detector which isn't bother her if
you could have taken a flight uh you may
be aware of machines like this oh my
gosh but the problem is he's not on his
joy so he's going to delete it in a lot
of trouble yeah so he's he's pissed off
ok police run in or so he's running but
he's gonna have to run cuz he's gonna
die like he's bleeding he's
tagged as a downer there is someone
that's not on the joy which is basically
saying you are not a fun person like the
lame person at the party exactly so he
is run that he is running one thing he
might be able to do is he might be able
to find a joy booth a joy booth is
basically a place where you can get joy
if you need so oh no he died Oh No so
now we start again from scratch from
scratch so that's that's pivoted right
my death yeah yeah well that's the good
thing about procedural generation is
that when you do these things again and
again and again you get to just play it
again as if it was the first time
because everything feels new that's
right so you can't just learn exactly
everything is in the world you have to
understand how the game works and the
more you learn obviously the better
you'll get in the game and eventually
you'll be able to escape so even though
it's procedural though we were gonna end
up going through that bridge right like
that's yes that's forced area that
you're gonna have to go through to
continue the story that's absolutely
right it's one of the ways that we make
the game harder as you go along as we go
to control the Warriors are just a
difficulty based on where we think
you're being outside and how long is the
whole game play at this stage because if
it is permadeath I mean you're gonna be
constantly playing this beginning or
there any like how long do you keep
going before you actually so right now
it or learn how to be happy forever
right now in the game I mean it's about
an hour and a half okay you can you can
complete the game within that but it's
aiming for around about three hours or
so right and what's fantastic about this
is that even though when you do
successfully complete it because of the
because its fruity procedurally
generated you can play it again and try
to figure out a different way almost in
like the new Metal Gear kind of style
away like how else can I solve this
exactly so you've got a bunch of
different things that work with that
you've got different gameplay styles you
can run around you can hit everybody
with your branch that he's got right
there's okay get weapons you can fight
through you can stealth through and try
and be avoid everybody but I think the
most interesting part of gameplay is
what we call social blinking which is
really all about conformity so if you're
not being suspicious these guys won't
bother you well actually these guys
oh he's gonna have to run i feel like
when i played this there was no way i
could blend in i couldn't find a way for
them to not hate my guts and i tried
really hard to look cool and nobody was
having it well part of the problem is
that this is still very early in our
development right so this is pre alpha
and we just made this biome that you're
in right now we just made that like four
weeks ago all right so all these all
these wastrels running around they are
really new to the game and so they they
hate everybody but once you get past
that bridge you get into the the part of
town we called the village okay and
that's where the people really start to
pay attention to what you're doing or
not they don't just run after you so if
G over there can actually manage to get
into the village would be able to he's
struggling to the right kinds of things
he needs to craft a lockpick so you can
open the door so but there is like full
crafting in this game absolutely come in
later do you end up getting better
weapons besides a branch oh yeah yeah
you could like a really hot brunt
alright yeah fine it with other elements
yeah like put two brothers together and
make a super bra yeah so we have we have
a bunch of weapons in the game right now
but they're all really early stages so
we've got like pipes and we've got a
cricket bat which is particularly
enjoyable they take damage yep so um
durability system so you've got to be
really careful about when you get into
combat and when you don't because you
don't really want to be fighting in this
game unless you absolutely have to okay
so there's a lot of survival in this as
well because there's food apparently i
can i can get hungry it looks like i can
absolutely i eventually will lose health
what about you must have like some kind
of bandage system for when I bleed him
yeah so right now you can heal yourself
I don't think she has got anything that
he can craft yet but this is our
crafting system so there are yet basic
weapons there are gadgets that you can
use to distract or you know incapacitate
people there are food and drink but the
key thing is that the water throughout
the city is mostly drugged with joy okay
and if you take too much joy you will
actually overdose so you have to find
clean safe ways of eating
so the game is about yet sure you can
get food but is it the right kind of
like such a dark element of life to this
where it's like you're gonna figure out
it take some drugs but not too many
drugs yeah yeah it's it's kind of a
mockery of the whole prescription drug
culture okay we have going on and it's
like you couldn't take any kind of drug
for any kind of problem that you have
but obviously there's always a side
effect right yeah that's what the game
is about memory hangovers things like
that well Sam thank you so much for
showing me we happy for you I think this
is gonna be like really amazing i'm
looking forward to when it comes out
when is that well we're actually the
middle of a kickstarter right now so we
are fairly far away from the game coming
up but n equal incentives for backers oh
there's a few you can actually get
access to the game as soon as the
kickstarter ends through a pre-alpha
tier okay so you can start playing right
away and watch us develop the game
that's pretty cool and then there are a
whole bunch of other things that you can
do to get inside the game if you want to
sweet yeah well thank you so much that
was we happy few you can check it out
now the Kickstarter is currently ongoing
and for all your III news and everything
else game-related be sure to head to
gamespot com